now and in France Nationwide strikes
against President Emmanuel macron's
proposed pension reforms are underway
the government announced plans to raise
the retirement age by two years to 64.
these are live pictures out of Paris
where unions have joined protesters
saying the move is an assault on the
welfare system Railways schools and
refineries will be affected by workers
walking off the job joining us live now
from the capital city is Bernard Smith
hello there Bernard what's the level of
opposition to these pension reforms by
the looks of the crowds there are
thousands of people taking part in the
demonstrations
[Music]
Emily most French people accept the need
to reform their pension system but
almost 70 percent of them are opposed to
the type of Reform Emmanuel macron is
trying to push through that is
increasing the retirement age to 64.
people are more interested in other
Solutions perhaps increasing employer
benefits or taxing the super rich now 12
of France's main unions have got
together to lead these protests today
that in itself is unusual in France the
unions are rarely United like this and
they're hoping to turn this protest and
just to combine it with concerns about
the continuing cost of living crisis
into a social protest movement so much
of that whether they succeeding doing
that really depends on how many people
how many thousands of people take to the
streets not just here in Paris but in
the rest of the country
and Bernard why is macron pushing ahead
with these reforms despite such
opposition
a lot of is to do with the Legacy that
Emmanuel macron wants to leave he cast
himself in his first term as a reforming
president he tried to push through
pension reforms then Mass protests
forced him into a retreat and then the
pandemic happened so for the second it
was very second term his final term he
can't run again he's again wants to
create this image and leave this Legacy
as a reformer he's only so far been
managing France through various crises
this has got to be passed by the French
Parliament macron's party lost his
majority there in the last election so
he's relying on support from the
conservative the Republicans party they
have indicated but they might support
him but aren't fully behind him so far
if he doesn't get that he can use a
constitutional amendment to force
through the reforms but it's sort of a
last-ditch thing that and if he does
that that core could force new
legislative elections Emily all right
make sure you let us know how the
afternoon develops Bernard Smith Library
in Paris thank you
let's take a closer look now at those
proposed reforms by President macron he
says the changes needed to ensure the
pension system remains viable but in a
recent poll 80 percent of those surveyed
were against it at the moment the
retirement age is 62 lower than many
developed countries the plan is to raise
it to 64 by the year 2030 to qualify a
worker who currently needs to contribute
to the system for 42 years will have to
contribute 443 or 44. the minimum
pension for low-income workers who've
worked full-time throughout their
careers will be increased by about 100 a
month to 85 percent of the net minimum
wage about thirteen hundred dollars a
month parental leave would now be
included in the pension calculation
earlier I spoke with Anne Elizabeth
moutte who is a political columnist for
the telegraph she says the pension
reform has been a long and protracted
issue across France
what they're saying is that the generous
French welfare system in that view is
being eroded by uh uh um slow
incremental measures in the past 25 to
30 years that have led to the average
pension being a lower than it used to be
in absolute terms
um this is perfectly true this this
reform is one of several reforms that
was won by Allah pay in 1995 there was
one by Nicola Sarkozy was there was one
on the first world every president looks
at the at the pension reform and sees
that we have an unsustainable problem we
have a pay-as-you-go system which means
that uh people who are at work pay for
people who have already retired it's not
like a pension pot and uh in 1946 when
this was created uh you had eight people
working to pay for the pension of one
pensioner that has changed we now have
something like two people paying for one
pensioner which of course is
unsustainable but on the other hand the
feeling among the workers in France and
and the unions is that uh this reform is
essentially uh pushing people to work
longer when they will not find jobs
because in France unemployment problems
uh um always had structural employment
you know between eight and ten percent
and also because French employers fire
people after 50 anyway so what they say
is we are forcing people to have a worse
life with no jobs available for them not
to retire from